Get ready for more Eddie.
A post has sprung up on Reddit from a user
in Russia who claims to have seen a leaked
trailer for the upcoming Venom 2.
While we haven't gotten a glimpse of it stateside
yet, the Redditor helpfully provided a full
breakdown for us to chew on.
While it seems like pretty much every 2020
film release has been pushed back to the fall
in the wake of the ongoing COVID-19 outbreak,
it looks like Venom 2 will benefit from already
having been slated for release in that frame.
The flick is due in theaters on October 2,
and so far, that release date has held firm.
Fans of 2018's Venom were floored when, in
the flick's post-credits sequence, they were
introduced to a very dangerous inmate with
whom Eddie Brock had lined up an interview:
Cletus Kasady, a brutal serial killer who
is destined to become the insanely dangerous
symbiotic villain Carnage.
"Hi, Eddie."
"Hey."
"Do you mind if we forego the whole creepy
serial killer thing, here?"
According to our Russian Redditor, the trailer
for Venom 2 will give us our first, fleeting
look at Kasady in full-on Carnage mode - while
also teasing the plot device which puts the
murderer on a collision course with our favorite
tongue-y antihero.
Of course, we must state before we go any
further that this leak is in no way confirmed,
and it may just be the product of one Venom
fan's fertile imagination.
Also, the events of the trailer - and its
dialogue - have been translated to English
from Russian with an online translator, so
we're basically just going to have to run
down the synopsis as best we can with the
information we have.
Having said all that, the leak sounds pretty
legit - and it also sounds like Venom 2 is
going to be pretty freakin' awesome.
According to the Reddit post, the trailer
opens with a shot of San Francisco, as a voiceover
lauds Venom as a new protector of the city.
"You go anywhere in the city, preying on innocent
people, and we will find you and eat both
of your arms and then both of your legs."
We then see a group of children trick-or-treating,
but they've come to the wrong house: The door
is answered by Kasady, who removes his Halloween
mask to reveal that his face is starting to...well,
Carnage out.
He then laughs, and the trailer cuts away.
We then see Kasady pursuing Brock in a car
chase, with police on both their tails.
Then, Brock is seen checking out a newspaper
clipping about an orphanage burning down.
There's then a bit of conversation between
Brock and the Venom symbiote, with Brock indicating
something to the effect that Carnage is just
getting started - again, the translation here
isn’t great.
Then, there's a scene of Brock transforming,
and Venom scaling the outside of a church
where Kasady is holed up.
The spot fades to black, and Carnage is heard
in voiceover saying that his goal is more
than just, well, wanton carnage.
Before cutting to black, the trailer ends
with a brief scene of a cop shooting at Kasady,
who stops the bullet with a gnarly tentacle
- and then, the cop screaming in terror as
Kasady begins to transform.
"Carnage…is…CHAOS!!"
Again, even though the leak is far from confirmed
and the translation is rough, we're cautiously
optimistic that our Russian Redditor did indeed
catch a sneak peek of the Venom 2 trailer.
The description above a) follows all of the
typical beats of a standard superhero movie
teaser trailer, and b) is pretty much exactly
what we would expect, teasing the confrontation
between Venom and Carnage without giving away
too much of the movie's plot.
Of course, we should know for certain whether
or not this leak is legit sooner rather than
later.
Like we mentioned, Venom 2 is still holding
fast to its October release date, and - assuming
that there are no setbacks between now and
then - that only gives Sony about five months
to promote the flick.
Dropping a teaser trailer sooner rather than
later would be a pretty good way to get fans
totally psyched for what might be one of their
first chances to catch a major movie in the
theater post-COVID quarantine.
And, since Venom cleared $850 million at the
worldwide box office, the sequel certainly
qualifies as "major."
You know us - we'll be keeping an eye out
for any official word on the leak, or better
yet, an actual trailer drop.
As soon as we have either, we'll be beating
down your door with the news.
"When I get out of here, and I will, there's
gonna be carnage."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.